good morning John I'm gonna doughnut
someone out there in the world like you
I think
any genes from
to drive me crazy
Google hecklers I'm out a bit of a
whirlwind week it's been a little bit
saying but now simple just go and this
play this cool envelope bikes you can
borrow take him around started off to
Seattle where I saw what I thought was
the largest window ever and then I went
to Los Angeles and saw a bunch of
convention centers where the windows
were much larger than that one in
Seattle and I'm at Google which is
pretty amazing fairyland of a place to
be honest and now they gave me you know
I officially have an office at Google
look at me look at it I officially
actually just walked into this room I
opened the door and I walked in there's
a plug and there's a desk and I
I needed to edit my video ah careful
camera don't fall over
you're expensive it's weird here you
know that recently people found out that
Google had been driving a car that was
driving itself and the driver wasn't
driving and it was driving all around
California and nobody knew about it
people who work on things like that
they called them product development
product developers it's kind of like
saying up my job is that I'm a stuff
maker I make stuff that almost freaks me
out like sometimes you know how recently
scientists said that they could not
possibly make a human chimpanzee hybrid
and that's kind of like an interesting
and cool idea but of course you never
wouldn't do that
really immoral but it's scientifically
it's very fascinating very fascinating
idea I feel like 70 floors below me
right now there is a Humanzee
and there but another great school and
you know maybe the lake my Humanzee
girlfriend at some point honestly it's
just a business field of people who come
together and make the things that make
our lives better they seem very happy
like very nice people the food is
delicious almost certain that there's
nothing any kind of chimeras it's really
a good place ah
and if you were actually curious why I
was in Los Angeles why does my finger
smell like chocolate why am I not
editing this out of the video working on
Vika I was working on VidCon in Los
Angeles and now I'm here at Google to
attend the first Google only stop of the
Digi tour which I'm very excited about
maybe coming to a place near you just
google it it's a good chance it's gonna
be the city near you
Thank You Dallas David the song playing
the background of this video is called
hard to talk about in parrot stories
John I hope that you weren't do jealous
that I'm the first vlogger that they've
got to go to the Mountain View campus of
Google I will see you on a day
stuff on TV
be real good